immer wenn maria bergmann den
briefkasten öffnet hat sie ein ungutes
gefühl
seit monaten bekommt die tv-journalistin
immer wieder post von inkassofirmen und
anwälten
sie ist eine von tausenden bestell
betrugsopfern in deutschland insgesamt
sind mehr als 6000 euro an forderungen
aufgelaufen
6100 euro mara bergmann soll bei
mehreren online-shops waren auf rechnung
bestellt aber nicht bezahlt haben
in den schreiben ist von rechtlichen
schritten die rede
es drohen schufa-einträge gerichtliche
mahnverfahren maria bergmann muss sich
ans telefon hängen stunden lang um zu
erklären dass sie nie etwas bestellt hat
meistens hatte ich es bei den us open
mit callcentern zu tun manche wand und
zuvorkommend und habe gesagt oh das kann
gut sein wir haben ganz ganz häufig
betrugsfälle
das kann gut sein dass da jemand ihre
daten missbraucht um fleißig shoppen zu
gehen aber es gab wirklich auch menschen
die haben mir das gefühl gegeben
schwerkriminelle zu sein weil so super
nervig emotional total mara bergmann
erfährt dass sie sechs paar damenschuhe
bestellt haben soll babyklamotten für
400 euro
eine espressomaschine ein vierteiliges
pannenset und designermöbel
von all dem hat sie nichts bemerkt denn
die pakete gingen laut händler an eine
ganz andere adresse dass die adressen
lassen die wahlen gegangen
die betrüger hatten leichtes spiel bei
ihren bestellungen gaben sie nur mara
bergmanns namen an ihr geburtsdatum und
eine fake e mail adresse
das genügte den shops um die ware auf
rechnung zu verschicken ihre echte
anschrift fanden sie erst später aus es
ist unfassbar einfach in deutschland mit
wenigen daten shoppen zu gehen im netz
und schon habe ich für viele tausend
euro möglicherweise ware bestellt und
das ist viel zu einfach finde ich dinge
bestellen auf rechnungen und am ende hat
dann irgend jemand der nichts damit zu
tun hat den ärger es für den natürlich
super blöd auch wenn maria bergmann
keine der forderungen begleichen musste
hatte sie doch monatelang ärger
[Musik]
das problem hier ist der rechnungskauf
der von fast allen online-shops in
deutschland angeboten wird eine
einladung an betrüger denn viele händler
überprüfen die identität des bestellers
gar nicht oder nicht gut genug
und das hat folgen seit jahren
expandiert der online-handel und mit ihm
wächst auch der bestell betrug
wir haben bei allen 16
landeskriminalämtern nachgefragt überall
steigen die fallzahlen während die
aufklärungsquoten sinken
57.000 fälle wurden 2009 10 in ganz
deutschland zur anzeige gebracht eine
hohe dunkelziffer wird vermutet doch
nicht einmal jeder dritte fall konnte
aufgeklärt werden
die polizei muss deswegen prioritäten
setzen und aussichtslose fälle von
vornherein aussortieren
bei der vielzahl von ungefähr 19.000
taten die ja hier im raum steht müssen
wir schon bei vorgangs eingang relativ
schnell so eine tat klassifizieren
das heißt wir entscheidend früh ob es
sinn macht hier tiefer einzusteigen und
in welchen fällen wäre das so ein
entscheidender punkt ist irgendwann muss
der täter ja auch aus der deckung kommen
das heißt er muss versuchen physisch in
den besitz des paketes zu kommen das
gegenstand ist der wahre und da können
wir natürlich auch zugreifen indem wir
vor ort sind das heißt das muss man sich
so vorstellen dass sie dann im zweifel
sich von den briefkasten stelle oder
adresse stellen und dort jemanden
abfangen wir richten unsere kapazitäten
darauf aus den täter dann zu ergreifen
wenn er aus der deckung kommt wenn ihr
das paket in empfang nehmen will
und dann wollen wir zur stelle sein doch
das wissen auch die täter sie sind gut
organisiert und schicken oft ahnungslose
menschen vor die bestellte ware
anzunehmen
es sind menschen wie an den ich in
augsburg treffe auch erst opfer von
organisierten bestell betrügern geworden
jan der eigentlich anders heißt war ein
sogenannter paket agent
er glaubte für eine logistikfirma zu
arbeiten
tatsächlich steckte eine bestell
betrüger bande dahinter
deshalb möchte er anonym bleiben über
200 pakete oft mit teurer elektronik
leitete er in osteuropäische länder
weiter ohne zu wissen dass er teil eines
kriminellen netzwerkes war einen lohn
hat er nie bekommen dafür jede menge
ärger denn die betrogenen online händler
warten sich an ihnen den paket empfänger
und zeigten ihn wegen betrugs und
geldwäsche an vom leben im boden
[Musik]
heute weiß er dass er damals naiv war
als jan klar wird dass er betrogen wurde
geht er zur polizei und zeigte sich
selbst an am ende hat jan glück gehabt
das ermittlungsverfahren gegen ihn wurde
eingestellt
ich will mehr über den organisierten
bestell betrug herausfinden und lasse
mich anwerben über eine kleinanzeige
dafür er finde ich rebecca martinz und
in serie einen job gesucht
nach einigen wochen bekomme ich eine
verdächtige mail eine angebliche
logistik firma bietet mir einen 450 euro
job als versand leiterin an
ich soll zu hause ein mini lager für den
empfang und versand von paketen
einrichten
also bekommt rebecca martins eine
wohnanschrift und ein skype konto
der kontakt zu den betrügern läuft nur
online ich hätte mit selina meiner
projekt managerin selina ist natürlich
ihr bild stammt aus einer fotodatenbank
auch das unternehmen für das sich
arbeiten soll ist fällt die betrüger
benutzen den namen einer existierenden
logistikfirma mit einem professionellen
internetauftritt damit soll jobsuchenden
wie mir seriosität vorgetäuscht werden
ziemlich schnell bekomme ich meinen
arbeitsvertrag und bald auch schon das
erste paket die betrüger haben bei media
markt auf den namen rebecca martins eine
grafikkarte bestellt wert etwa 480 euro
das paket soll ich öffnen den inhalt
fotografieren und selina ein beweisfoto
schicken
dann bekomme ich von ihr einen versand
aufkleber mit einer adresse in polen
was selina nicht weiß ich nehme die
bestellte ware aus dem paket heraus und
lege stattdessen einen gps tracker
hinein
so kann ich den weg der warensendung
verfolgen
wie gut solche betrüger banden
organisiert sind erfahre ich bei der
staatsanwaltschaft in dresden
ihr gelang es 2018 einen internationalen
bestell betrüger ring auszuheben und den
kopf der bande hinter gitter zu bringen
exemption auf deutsch befreiung so sein
deckname baute ein netzwerk von rund 200
komplizen auf die ware mit gestohlenen
zugangsdaten bestellten und zu geld
machten auch in diesem verzweigten
system wurden paket agenten als
zustelladresse benutzt um die spur der
drahtzieher zu verschleiern
die schwierigkeiten bestehen zum einen
natürlich darin dass der arbeits theilig
vorgegangen wird wir haben hier so eine
art spinnennetz mit ganz ganz vielen
beteiligten und das macht es natürlich
relativ schwer dem auf die schliche zu
kommen
wir müssen ins ausland gucken wir müssen
rechtshilfeersuchen machen
es werden also ganz viele mechanismen
von den kriminellen eingebaut um die
taten möglichst erfolgreich zu
verschleiern als paket agentin
undercover merke auch ich wie schwer es
ist an die drahtzieher zu kommen über
wochen hätte ich mit den betrügern und
stelle ihnen fallen so genannte
honeypots von jedem ankommenden paket
wollen sie beweisfotos sehen die schicke
ich ihnen aber nicht direkt sondern nur
einen link auf einen server so
hinterlässt jeder zugriff auf die bilder
datenspuren ip-adressen doch meine
projekt managerin selina verschleiert
ihre ip-adresse ihr komplize dem ich
meinen arbeitsvertrag schicken soll
tappt in die falle der server speichert
seine ip-adresse
es ist die eines krankenhauses in mainz
von dort hat er mich kontaktiert das
krankenhaus will mir keine weiteren
auskünfte geben und die polizei
einschalten
diese spur endet hier
inzwischen stapeln sich elf pakete an
meiner tür adresse darin tablets ein
iphone controller aber auch ein lego
porsche eigentlich soll ich die ware an
eine adresse in polen weiterleiten
doch ich informiere die betrogenen
online-händler und lasse mir sämtliche
daten geben die die betrüger bei ihrer
bestellung hinterlassen haben und jetzt
wird ein muster erkennbar
neun der elf paketsendungen wurden mit
gestohlenen paypal-konten bezahlt
[Musik]
hat der zahlungsdienstleister ein
sicherheitsproblem wie bestell betrüger
an gestohlene paypal-konten kommen
können zeigt mir der it experte daniel
moßbrucker er macht mit mir einen exkurs
ins darknet dort gibt es händler
plattformen die alles verkaufen was
illegal ist
drogen waffen und auch gefischte
bezahldaten zugangsdaten für paypal
konten gibt es hier schon ab 10 dollar
wir finden einen händler der auch paypal
konten deutscher kunden verkauft gezahlt
wird in bitcoins macht mich aber dass
ich gehe so genannten checkout genau ein
einkaufswagen und dann genau 1495 mit
cookie hat funktioniert und da wir haben
jetzt den namen so haben wir zum namen
verrückt und so eine adresse in berlin
adresse in berlin nicht das beste
passwort ist so sagen darf
unser darknet händler liefert alles
namen adresse bankverbindung und
passwort des paypal kunden außerdem den
sogenannten session cookie eigentlich
eine sicherheitsvorkehrung von paypal
das alles ist elegant das kann man sich
vorstellen wie so ein kleiner geheimtipp
den paypal uns in den browser legt damit
paypal sozusagen jedesmal auslesen kann
ja diesen nutzer kenne ich so da war ich
schon mal so dass ich dann als betrüger
mir den cookie in meinen eigenen browser
setzen kann und dann paypal denkt ja
klar den browser hatte ich ja schon mal
so wird paypal als sicherheitsvorkehrung
von online-kriminellen einfach
ausgehebelt
da muss man dann nicht auch fragen ob
paypal sicherheitsvorkehrungen da gut
genug sein wenn das jetzt so leicht
möglich ist am ende habe ich für einen
milliardenkonzern die wie paypal es ist
wahrscheinlich ein stückweit eingepreist
das irgendwie pro tag 200 vielleicht
sind ein paar tausend ich weiß es nicht
menschen gefischt werden ich glaube für
so ein riesenkonzern wir wollen paypal
nach sicherheitsproblemen durch phishing
fragen doch der online-bezahldienst
lehnt ein interview ab schriftlich heißt
es paypal überprüft fortlaufend
fragwürdige kontoaktivitäten um
sicherzustellen dass betrügerische
transaktionen sowie illegale aktivitäten
verhindert werden
aber reicht das aus bestell betrüger
nutzen immer wieder gehackte paypal
konten der it sicherheitsexperte david
vorfindet das paypal es phishing
betrügern zu einfach macht und zeigt mir
das an einem beispiel
wichtigstes merkmal von phishing-mails
ist die weiterleitung auf externe seiten
und genau das tut paypal aber selbst der
zahlungsdienstleister verschickt
massenmails und verlinkt diese nicht auf
people.com sondern auf eine paypal
communications website
etwas ungeschickt an
also man filme zwar ratschläge auf der
webseite dass man auf phishing nicht
hereinfallen soll und was das und die
indikatoren sind auf die man achten
sollte
aber dann sehen die legitimen massen
mails von paypal selber so ähnlich aus
wie sehr gut gemachte phishing-mails
aber nicht nur das vermutlich hätte der
missbrauch gefischt hat daten mit der so
genannten starken kunden
authentifizierung verhindert werden
können
dabei muss der nutzer seine identität
doppelt verifizieren zum beispiel mit
einer tan bei banktransaktionen längst
üblich zwar bietet paypal die starke
kunden authentifizierung seit jahren an
doch nur auf freiwilliger basis erst
jetzt werden die nutzer darauf
hingewiesen bei paypal diese zusätzliche
sicherheitsmaßnahme zum 31 12 2020
verpflichtend einführen muss so schreibt
es der gesetzgeber vor
und warum hat sich paypal damit so lange
zeit gelassen bis auf den letzten
drücker das einzuführen
die weißen sicherheitsmaßnahmen sind
nicht umsonst zu haben aber vor allem
ist die gefahr für die firmen dass sie
einen gewissen anteil ihrer nutzer
verlieren
deswegen gibt es ein interesse daran die
umsetzung dieser maßnahmen möglichst
weit nach hinten zu schieben bis man
wirklich gezwungen ist das heißt also
für die zahlungsdienstleister und für
paypal ist das eine knallharte kosten
nutzen rechnung das ist so das ist für
alle wirtschaftsunternehmen so
zurück zu meinem paket agenten job wir
folgen der spur unseres trackers den wir
in einem der pakete versteckt haben bis
an polens ostgrenze und hoffen den
bestell betrügern vor ort auf die spur
zu kommen
das paket wurde im offset zugestellt
einem kleinen dorf nur wenige kilometer
von der ukrainischen grenze entfernt
adressiert war das paket an einen arthur
polanski max mustermann auf polnisch
sagt meine übersetzerin
wir klingeln einfach mal an der
zustelladresse
[Musik]
arthur polanski er ist nicht hier aber
er wohnt hier
nein nur päckchen auf seinen namen
kommen hier an waren viele pakete es gab
wohl probleme damit
irgendwie waren da ziegelsteine drin
ziegelsteine wohl eher unser trecker und
wo sind die päckchen hingegangen
der mann spricht von einem lager im
nachbardorf meer weißer nicht denn seine
tochter hat die pakete weitergeleitet
wir glauben dass das betrüger sind sie
verschwenden ihre zeit ich kann ihnen
dazu nichts sagen
ob die junge frau zur betrüger bande
gehört oder selbst nur eine ahnungslose
paket agenten ist können wir nicht
klären
aber eines wissen wir unser paket wurde
weiterverschickt der trecker zeigt an
dass jemand es über die grenze brachte
in die ukraine ab hier sendet der
trecker nicht mehr und auch diese spur
verliert sich also wieder dasselbe
muster auch diese bestell betrügerbande
versteckt sich im eu-ausland und
bedrückt den deutschen online-handel
und dann gelingt es mir doch noch einen
bestell betrüger zu sprechen exemption
den kopf der bestell betrügerbande dem
die justiz jahrelang auf der spur war
und ihn schließlich hinter gitter
brachte
wegen corona dürfen wir ihn nicht im
gefängnis besuchen sondern nur mit ihm
telefonieren exemption ein russe ist
gelernter buchhalter und hat den
deutschen online-handel um 13 millionen
euro betrogen
wir führen das interview mit hilfe einer
übersetzerin
mich würde interessieren warum sie sich
ausgerechnet deutschland als zielland
ausgesucht haben ich habe auch andere
länder ausprobiert und bin dann dabei
geblieben dass es deutschland sein soll
warum denn deutschland kann man da so
leicht bestehen dass sich leute so
leichtgläubig in deutschland das
sicherheitssystem in deutschland ist im
vergleich zu anderen ländern am
schwächsten
aus diesem grund ist es am einfachsten
in deutschland zu bestellen
exemption bestätigt unsere vermutung
sicherheitslücken im deutschen
online-handel locken betrüger an
deutsche online händler können sich
nicht selbst schützen
sie beauftragen andere unternehmen ja
auch paypal aber nicht nur schuld daran
sind unternehmen die schutzmechanismen
für online händler zur verfügung stellen
die die zahlungsabwicklung machen für
viele online händler übernehmen
zahlungsdienstleister wie ratepay
billpay oder clara das ausfallrisiko
sie sind nach eigenen angaben darauf
spezialisiert betrugsversuche zu
erkennen
doch im fall lara bergmann sind gleich
mehrere zahlungsdienstleister daran
gescheitert die betrügerischen
bestellungen auf rechnung zu erkennen
ist die betrugserkennung der
zahlungsdienstleister tatsächlich eine
schwachstelle für bestell betrüger
wie gut die betrugserkennung bei
zahlungsdienstleistern funktioniert will
ich von ratepay wissen einem der
führenden auf dem deutschen markt die
angehende geschäftsführerin nina prinz
erklärt uns das schon während des
bestellvorgangs eine risikoanalyse läuft
die betrugsversuche erkennen kann
besonders riskant ist der kauf auf
rechnung dennoch bietet ihn fast jeder
händler an
der kauf auf rechnung der ist ja in
deutschland immer noch die beliebteste
bezahlmethode das schöne ist eben daran
dass der käufer die ware erst erhält und
sie danach bezahlt und wenn
online-händler die beliebten
bezahlmethoden anbieten dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit natürlich auch größer
dass käufer den kauf abschließen wenn
ich das bezahlen zu schwierig mache
kauft keiner mehr wenn man kein umsatz
mehr als online-händler der umsatz
machen will muss also auch den riskanten
rechnungskauf anbieten um das risiko zu
minimieren werden zahlungsdienstleister
wie ratepay beauftragt die darauf
spezialisiert sind verdächtige
bestellungen zu erkennen
was ist da für sie verdächtigt
verdächtig sind wenn es plötzlich
abweichen e mail adressen sind vom
kundenprofil oder wenn das komische ip
adressen sind oder e mail adressen die
stark von dem namen abweichen den wir
haben da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche
daten punkte die wir prüfen also das
modell schlägt alarm wenn bestimmte
parameter einfach nicht zusammen passen
also im endeffekt prüfen sie keine
ausweise wirkliche identität bisher
später mara bergmann nicht kann ja gar
nicht prüfen und weil sie es nicht war
wir arbeiten damit auskunft teilen
zusammen also findet immer die
überprüfung statt aber der betrüger kann
ja auch in anderen namen annehmen genau
der fall den sie beschrieben haben also
den identitätsbetrug den karni zu 100
prozent verhindern
beim rechnungskauf kommt die
betrugserkennung schnell an ihre grenzen
wenn eine gestohlene identität benutzt
wird auch vorkasse über paypal bietet
betrügern leichtes spiel
solange eine starke authentifizierung
fehlt
was für den online-handel anscheinend
ein kalkuliertes risiko ist bedeutet für
die justiz viel arbeit zu viel arbeit
findet der berliner oberstaatsanwalt
rudolf hausmann
er fürchtet dass die fallzahlen mit dem
boomende onlinehandel weiter steigen
schon 2009 10 kann die berliner justiz
mit knapp 19.000 fällen an ihre grenzen
was bedeutet so eine masse an delikten
ja das bedeutet dass eine komplette
abteilung der staatsanwaltschaft ein
jahr lang nur an diesem verfahren
arbeitet mit einem sehr überschaubaren
man könnte auch sagen eher dürftigen
ergebnis ist es einfach nicht hinnehmbar
denn wir haben andere aufgaben
schwerpunktsetzungen zum beispiel im
bereich des internationalen islamismus
alles das lässt sich vermeiden wenn der
gesetzgeber an der stelle den dann regel
vorsteht und sagt mit gewisses
mindestmaß an überprüfung was die
identität der besteller betrifft müssen
wir einfach verlangen nach unseren
recherchen prüft fast kein online shop
die tatsächliche identität des
bestellers so wie zb bei der eröffnung
eines bankkontos mit dem postident
verfahren weil händler in deutschland
außerdem oft auf vorkasse verzichten ist
betrügen ziemlich einfach
solange nutzer bei bestellvorgängen
nicht eindeutig identifizierbar sind
schützt die anonymität des netzes
bestell betrügern wie sicher der online
handel ist bleibt bis auf weiteres eine
risikoabwägung der händler und
zahlungsdienstleister in zweifel geht
umsatz vor sicherheit dass die
allgemeinheit und justiz schaden nehmen
wird dabei in kauf genommen
[Musik]